uh water rocket engine Cycles getting I
think getting more to you towards your
shirt question you have a really good
video called that uh I mean a lot of
your videos that are technical are just
exceptionally well done so I just I
think
um
you deserve all the props you get I mean
thank you for for doing this work really
really really really really well done uh
so it's called rocket engine Cycles how
do you power a rocket engine and you go
through all the different options is
there something you could say about uh
open cycle close cycle full flow all the
different variants that you can use
words to explain yeah without all the
pretty pictures yeah without the pretty
pictures so ultimately you know like we
said we your ultimate goals you want to
get heat and pressure into an engine so
obviously at some point you can either
make really thick tanks of your rocket
you can like get it so thick that you
store the propellants at really really
high pressures but obviously like that
doesn't scale very well at some point
your Rocket's so heavy you can't even
leave the ground or you know it's just
so much of your mass is just literally
the walls of the rocket so at some point
people realize hey we could actually
just pump the fuels and the oxidizer
into the engine at a high pressure and
increase the pressure through a pump now
obviously a pump is going to require
energy you have to get that energy from
somewhere
um and again at some point people were
like well Rockets are
there's already Rocket Fuel here you
know we'll just use some of the energy
from the rocket fuel to spin these pumps
so that that would be considered like
open cycle closed cycle full flow stage
combustion Cycles are are ways to
tap into the propellant actually and
then there's tap off expanders like I
mean all of them kind of do the same
thing but you end up at some point
spinning a turbine uh you know a turbine
can take uh some of the heat energy and
the and the and the pressure
uh of an engine and then they can that
can be connected to a shaft to pumps and
those pumps can you know increase the
pressure of the propellants
and force it into the combustion chamber
now the difference between open cycle
closed cycle full flaw all those is what
happens
after the gas has flown through the
turbine so after you've used the turbine
and spun up the energy you know spun up
the engine what happens to that gas so
in an open cycle engine you basically
have like a separate small rocket engine
in a sense it's a gas generator they
call it and that will be used to create
someone you know take a little we'll say
10 of your the propellant flowing to the
engine instead you reroute it to like a
smaller rocket engine called the gas
generator you point that at your turbine
and that will spin your turbine up to
you know ridiculous speed it's 30 000
plus RPM and then after it spins it's
wasted most of its its energy you know
and it's just dumped overboard that
would be open cycle you're not worrying
about it after that point but you are
left with a lot of unburnt un you know
unused fuel a good amount of that fuel
is just completely and especially
because the turbine uh you you have to
keep it from melting so you can't run it
at like Optimal
ratios not necessarily stoichiometric
and a rocket engine you actually don't
want it to be near stoichiometric where
you're releasing all the energy you
actually want to release
um you actually want to be throwing out
the lighter molecule so it can be shot
out faster generally in the engine so um
but in order to have a turbine survive
you have to actually cool you have to
have the gas going through it it can't
be stupid stupid hot or else you're just
going to melt your turbine so they
normally um especially in the open cycle
you just run it really fuel Rich so
there's a lot of extra fuel being pumped
into it that will keep the temperatures
at a reasonable
uh you know at a reasonable temperature
so you end up with this like dark
smoke pouring out of that gas generator
that's just unburned fuel it's just
wasted fuel it never got a chance to be
used oh interesting you know like in the
combustion chamber it's not it's not
being used to propel the rocket you know
it's just being used to cool down the
the propellant that's being used to spin
the turbine that's being used to spin
the pumps to push a lot of propellant
into the engine
so
you know it doesn't take too long before
you know your a greedy rocket scientist
being like look at all this wasted
propellant all this potential energy
that's just literally being spewed out
the side of the rocket so that's where
the closed cycle comes in so now we have
to get that propellant take it from
basically
what was being wasted through the
turbine and you're going to try pumping
it back into the engine now you don't
literally just pump that that gas that's
you know that hot that gas into the
engine because it's actually way too low
of pressure uh compared to the main
combustion chamber by that point by the
time has gone through the turbine it's
lost most of its pressure and heat to
the turbine so if you tried pumping it
into the engine you know just taking
that pipe and sticking it right into the
combustion chamber that the much higher
pressure hotter combustion chamber will
just go backwards and it'd stall out the
engine and blow up the engine and
whatever what have you so what they
actually do is they normally will send
there might be some variations of this
but the general concept is you actually
flow all of your fuel or all of your
oxidizer through the turbine so that
would be closed cycle so there's fuel
Rich closed cycle which would be your
flowing all of the fuel through the
turbine or there's oxidizer closed cycle
which is where you're flowing all of the
oxidizer that's going into the engine
through the turbine now the trick here
is you have to have that turbine after
it's done its work so after it's taken
some of the potential energy some of the
heat energy from we're now calling it a
pre-burner by the way instead of it
being a gas generator you now call that
device that's that's creating pressure
to spin the turbine you're not calling
that a pre-burner because it's just
going to pre-burn some of your fuel or
some of your oxidizer
the trick is that has to be by the time
it's gone through the turbine it has to
be higher pressure
than the combustion chamber because
otherwise it's going to go backwards
still so you really have to get that
pre-burner up to ridiculously high
pressures like at least 20 higher than
your main combustion chamber and these
combustion Chambers you know we're
talking about engines that are at you
know 200 100 to 200 even in spacex's
Raptor engine up to 300 bar in the main
combustion chamber so that's what is
that 4500 PSI basically insane amounts
of of pressure inside these combustion
Chambers so your turbine has to be even
above that or your your gas generator or
your pre-burner sorry has to be higher
pressure than that even in order to have
the flow going the right direction
through the engine
so now you'll you'll have those closed
Cycles you'll have fuel Rich you have
oxidizer Rich
um the tricks now you're starting to get
it's crazy there's just so many
compromises every little decision you
have of like oh I did this now I know
well now crap it's gonna do this for
instance fuel Rich if you ran kerosene
fuel Rich you know how I mentioned soot
coming out of the gas generator well if
you run soot
um
through your through your engine like
that and had it go through your
injectors like back into the engine
it'll clog the pores of the injectors
and it will end up blowing up the engine
the soot itself is so damaging that you
can't really run a fuel-rich kerosene
engine what exactly is so it's like fuel
someone mixed up with the smoke like
what I wonder what what is it chemically
it's just some weird it's mostly just
carbon it's probably just that carbon
that dark solid solid chunks of carbon
and it can cake up and just literally
like you know like yeah it's it's like
ash almost you know like at some point
you know especially under those High
pressures and high temperatures it can
physically build up and you know turn
into like stalagmites and stalactites of
of carbon really hard
you know for forged in a rocket engine
carbon I wonder how you figure all that
out too is that's the experimentation
some of that has come chemist like
theoretical but like you're gonna have
to build the thing at scale and actually
test the trial and if you're trying here
there's many decades of trial and error
and many pieces of engines that you're
trying to piece back to they're going
like what the hell happened here yeah
what happened yeah okay so uh so that's
closed cycle so how do we get to full
flow so in either of those situations
you're still actually just having the
opposite so if you're fuel Rich you know
all the fuel is going through the
turbine but um only a tiny bit of oxygen
is actually being put into that
pre-burner to spin the pumps and the
rest of the the rest of the oxygen is
actually going through the pump the
primary pump and straight into the
combustion chamber
now full flow the idea is you're going
to actually pre-burn both your
propellants both your propellants are
going to go through a pre-burner and
they're both going to end up spinning
one of the pumps so you'll have a gas a
fuel rich pre-burner and you're going to
have an oxygen-rich pre-burner each one
of those is going to get just you know
they're going to heat it up just enough
and get it up to just enough pressure to
spin up that turbine as fast as they
need to do to get the pumps up to the
right pressure and still have enough
pressure through the turbine to overcome
the pressure inside the main combustion
chamber and they're both going to arrive
both your fuel and your oxidizer are
going to arrive in the main combustion
chamber as hot gases already so what was
liquid oxygen is now gaseous oxygen what
was Liquid methane is now gaseous
methane and they're meeting in this
combustion chamber at still ridiculously
high pressures again
for spacex's uh Raptor engine they're
meeting at 300 bar insane amounts of
pressure and then they uh then they
combust from there on and because
they're already a gas gas interaction
they're happy to burn they're ready to
they're ready to burn they're ready to
mingle as opposed to having a gas liquid
interaction which is what's a lot more
normal you know you'll have two
different states of matter and they just
might not they might take a little more
core you know coaxing to what's that
word
yeah
that doesn't sound like it's not correct
right focusing coaxing yeah yeah all
right I don't know we'll cut that in
post we'll have Morgan Freeman uh over
Davos yeah uh
the fascinating thing is they're coaxed
and there's gases and combustion but
yeah they they just take a little bit
more it takes more time in the
combustion chamber to have a liquid gas
interaction like mixed together and and
re unleash as much of their energy as he
can before it exits the system uh some
of the trade-offs here in terms of
efficiency which which is most efficient
and then also complexity of the design
and the engineering and the cost of the
design and the engineering like what are
the different trade-offs between open
cycle closed cycle and full flow yeah
it's a pretty it's kind of like a
oh what's the the Bears uh the
Goldilocks you know like it's like it
you kind of generally the easiest is
open cycle because you know you're just
expelling the the exhaust gas
um the gas generator exhaust you're not
having to worry about it you just spin
up that thing as much as you need and
deal with it right no big deal
um closed Cycles offers 10 to 15 greater
performance generally because you know
you're not wasting that propellant and
but it's it's complicated it's a lot
more complicated especially if you're
doing oxygen rich now you're having hot
gaseous oxygen uh in your engine which
just generally wants to react with
everything it's just a recipe like hot
oxygen is just a recipe for things to
catch on fire that shouldn't be on fire
so Metals you know under those
conditions lots of times we'll just
spontaneously start burning you know
you'll actually turn your metal and it
will now become fuel you'll be engine
Rich before you know it because you're
hot oxygen nice is uh is eating and
using that engine as fuel basically so
um oxygen rich is generally very hard
but that is what the Soviet Union ended
up doing with almost their entire line
of Vengeance was close cycle oxygen rich
but you know so those two are kind of
generally hard but offer great
performance benefits over open cycle uh
but at the end of the day you know full
flow is by far the it's the ultimate of
all of them it's the most difficult but
it also has the most potential to be the
most efficient Starship the Raptor two
the the why is that engine using full
flow
because it's the best I mean it's just
physics wise if you're trying to extract
as much energy out of your propellants
there there just isn't another cycle
type that that is uh better than it but
of course it's very very hard to develop
you know so far to date the rd270 in the
60s was built
um there is a powerhead demonstrator
built in the United States in the in the
90s and early 2000s I think maybe just
the early 2000s
um that was just the just the power Just
the the pumps and the turbines and the
pre-burners no chamber no nothing that
was a big deal only the United States
took you know millions of dollars to
just develop that and then there's
spacex's Raptor engine